few days ago researchers in Switzerland
announced the discovery of the Higgs
boson sometime a particle explains where
mass comes from in the universe the
important part is that it kind of caps
off the explanation of what's called the
standard model it's a the best cherry of
sub time of particles that comprise the
universe and the exciting thing about
this is that it's been predicted in
theory for decades so when human beings
find the thing it shows that we are
actually capable as a species of
apprehending the miracles of the
universe around us but I thought that
the coverage of the discovery was a
little bit um weird natha wasn't good a
lot of it really was and I really don't
want to get into a science journalism
navel-gazing thing because we do a lot
of that and I wouldn't lead us down that
rabbit hole but I thought that it was a
little bit like arch a lot of it had
this tone the mainstream stuff
especially at this tone of like Oh
science so hard and can be expensive and
what do we really get out of that and
you know I've also been reading a lot of
election year political journalism
indulging another Jones of mine and that
got me thinking about how those two
things overlap and which one of them is
objectively if you can put it this way
capital I important I've actually
covered both things I was a young
mediocre Washington journalist for a
while and I started to think back then
that the big difference between
political journalism and science
journalism was that if you're doing
science pretty much anybody would talk
to you scientists were excited to talk
about their findings the problem was
understanding what they were telling you
and and then conveying it to readers
viewers whatever in an engaging in
accurate and useful way and it's kind of
converse with politics where it was
really hard to get anybody to tell you
the truth on record the the the fact is
though that when they did what they were
saying tended to be sort of prosaic um
at least that was my experience of doing
that sort of coverage so I did this play
out well when I was a reporter in the
Washington bureau for Newsweek we all
used to at lunchtime sit around a big
round table and read the newspaper and
talk about what the important stories
were that day
I know newspapers and weekly news
magazines and paper I know I'm 400 years
old sorry but we'd sit around the table
and people say things like Oh new
political appointee here oh it's a you
know here's this trial how that's going
and and one afternoon at lunch I did the
same thing I look the paper and I said
hey these scientists just launched a new
kind of robot in the ocean that swims
like a salmon crickets they looked at me
like I was an alien which of course I
was right um you know to them that kind
of story those dyed-in-the-wool
excellent really high-level political
reporters to them that sort of story had
no bearing on people's everyday lives
now I know part of the problem is that
when we write about things like the
Higgs boson we take up huge chunks of
real estate and our stories with
explanation with boring exposition and
in political coverage they kind of don't
have to do that in fact if you were
going to criticize political covers
you'd say they aren't covering enough
policy there covering the horse race
right there doing all the interesting
drama they never have to explain what a
president is and how someone becomes
president where I'm back in the dust
talking about the standard model in the
bestie area of subatomic particles but I
think in my head I'm always going to
have the notion at least that the how
the universe works stories are more
important for lack of a better word than
the how the political process works
stories at least until the election
starts to come up and then the trend
lines move the other way and i'll be
reading the same political poll stories
that you all will but that's a statistic
story right just happen to have a
political outcome